thank you everyone for joining me today
i hope you're enjoying this lab roots
event
in this lecture i'd like to give you a
sense of the various forms of artificial
intelligence for biological image
analysis
and how we are using these powerful
tools to help researchers and clinicians
analyze the information within their
stains
ai is integrated into a lot of different
fields and we see evidence of the
advancements that it enables across our
daily lives
google has developed it to separate
buildings and streets from forests and
other objects
to increase the accuracy of google maps
the automotive industry is developing it
to analyze visual input and safely
maneuver cars to produce autonomous
vehicles
these tools are being developed for
finding the subtle differences between
objects
researchers and clinicians are also
beginning to utilize these powerful ai
tools
they are developing these artificial
intelligence methods like machine
learning and deep learning to help
analyze the biological information
within staining data
to uncover information that could be key
for understanding things like how the
cells and stroma in their
microenvironment
are altered to pathologically support
tumor growth seen here with a detailed
cellular phenotypic analysis
or to provide a more detailed and
accurate assessment for a diagnosis
seen here where we could have ai help us
see if the primary tumor has
metastasized
the terms artificial intelligence
machine learning and deep learning
are sometimes thrown around
interchangeably i want to define these
terms a bit
and give some examples to help clarify
what they are and how we can use them
with image data
i'll quickly run through the artificial
intelligence machine learning and deep
learning hierarchy
and give you a couple quick examples of
how these terms are applied
i'll then go through our ai classifiers
and describe which biological
application they are best suited for
then i'll go through some examples of
the best way to use these tools
in some staining data so artificial
intelligence is kind of the umbrella
term
it's classified as any technique that
enables computers to mimic general human
behavior machine learning is a category
of artificial intelligence
and is the ability to learn without
directly being programmed
so machine learning is a subcategory of
artificial intelligence
and is an example of an intelligent
classifier
it is something that can learn to
distinguish things on its own
and then a form of machine learning is
deep learning this is the learning of
underlying features in data
using deep neural networks which we'll
cover in a minute
so it's really a hierarchy of
terminology deep learning fits within
machine learning
and machine learning fits within
artificial intelligence
so down here you'll see a statement to
highlight this not all artificial
intelligence uses machine learning
and not all machine learning uses deep
learning so when people say hey we've
got this great new ai algorithm
a lot of people are referring to deep
learning but they're skipping some of
the descriptors
instead of specifically saying we are
using a deep learning classifier which
gives you a little bit more information
so be careful when people are talking
about ai because there's a lot of things
that are components of ai
so it's sometimes difficult to get a
clear idea of what they're talking about
other than the broad sense of something
that generally mimics human behavior
so we'll use a thermostat here as an
example to highlight some of these
differences
so if we start with a thermostat that
uses artificial intelligence
most people have used these old school
thermostats that allow you to adjust or
set temperatures in a room and maybe
program times that you want the
temperature to be at a certain degree
but all these do is adjust temperatures
to automatically turn on heating or
cooling units based on set thresholds
and these thresholds could be time or
temperature or both so instead of you
having to go
turn on the heater when you're cold or
turn on the ac unit when you're hot
this will actually mimic that behavior
and do it automatically for you
so this would be an example of
artificial intelligence not very
complicated but it is ai
so it's basically programmable to
automatically adjust so you can program
it to come on and off during different
times or different days
but it doesn't learn it simply follows
the orders that you're giving it
i want the temperature at 72 degrees
from seven in the morning until
four o'clock in the afternoon so it can
adjust temperature but it does so based
on your predefined program
that's the simplest form of ai
if we use the same thermostat analogy to
describe machine learning
which is a form of artificial
intelligence this would be the nest
thermostat so many of you have these or
know about them
but these are learning thermostats they
use sensory input primarily motion
detectors
to establish if a room is occupied it
has a period of learning so that it can
learn
occupants routines based on the sensor
input and adjust the temperature based
on this routine to conserve energy
so if you're gone for certain hours of
the day it can stop cooling the house
down during those times to save energy
and it can predict when you're coming
home to start cooling the room down
so this nest thermostat is defining
occupancy
as when the motion detector is triggered
it then knows that the room is occupied
and the correct temperature is
maintained
i believe they can also connect to wi-fi
and use the phone's location
within the home to know if there's
occupants if they don't happen to be
standing right in front of the
thermostat
either way the occupancy has a
definition when somebody is in the room
or the house
and it can learn routines based on
sensory input so it learns schedules or
routines without being directly
programmed
so then we have a thermostat that uses
deep learning which is a form of machine
learning which is a form of artificial
intelligence
this thermostat uses deep learning so it
uses convolutional neural networks
this thermostat can develop its own
definition of occupancy
and uses multiple inputs so it uses
motion sensors
sometimes from its own device or other
devices in the home
it can use speech recognition maybe from
an alexa or other inputs that it finds
useful to predict or understand what
occupancy is
and it is constantly learning from its
own learning and it defines its own
definition of occupancy and routines and
is constantly adjusting to those things
it can also redefine its definition of
occupancy should new data or sensors
enter the system or routines
change so as an example maybe the
thermostat is able to connect to the
weather
and it knows that tomorrow is going to
be 15 degrees cooler than it was today
and it hears people talking in the home
about the weather or that they're cold
or maybe their movements are slowed
and so it can proactively increase the
temperature by 5 or 10 degrees tomorrow
because the weather data is predicting
that it'll be a cooler day for example
so it can utilize all accessible
information to make those decisions
and that's what we're really talking
about the power of deep learning that
just can't be obtained with machine
learning
with the regular thermostat example that
we gave before so just to review
not all artificial intelligence uses
machine learning
and not all machine learning uses deep
learning
so now let's dive into this in a little
bit more detail on how they relate to
image analysis
all of the classifiers in the software
are ai classifiers but many of them fall
into either machine learning or deep
learning
we'll start with a threshold classifier
as the only ai
non-machine learning based classifier
many of you are already familiar with
threshold especially if you have already
worked with image analysis software to
some degree
a threshold is simply setting a cut
point where the objects or pixels above
or below a set value
are the object we want and the objects
or pixels on the other side of the cut
point
are what we don't want and what we're
going to consider background
so in the images on the right here you
can see that in this picture we want to
highlight pixels of a certain value
that are closer to the white side than
the black side
so this is a form of thresholding so
here we have a classifier that simply
defines rules or if statements
we program this classifier there's no
learning that takes place
so essentially it's the old thermostat
what temperature do you want and we'll
deliver when we hit that rule set
so in this image on the right you can
see we have these positive nuclei
and we just want to tag those pixels
that have a certain intensity of brown
so we set a threshold everything up to
175
and it tags those pixels seen here in
green in the following way
and then we can add post-processing
steps to clean it up a bit if we want
but simple
if we move to our machine learning
classifiers
so these are still ai classifiers but
threshold is not a machine
learning classifier and deep learning is
but we'll talk about this when we get to
deep learning
so the three that we have in the
software that we categorize as machine
learning for this example
are k-means clustering bayesian and
decision forest
so each of these has a different way of
distinguishing their pixels and how they
can create groups or classes
k-means can use both supervised and
unsupervised learning
invasion and decision forest both use
supervised learning
which we'll discuss on the next slide
but basically they're just trying to
distinguish different groups on their
own
so it's trying to create these cut
points to establish these differences
however these require defined features
just like thresholding we have to give
it input on what features we want
it to utilize to distinguish these
objects so maybe we can create features
that highlight the positive nuclei in
white
or we use something else that
distinguishes the gray regions
here we have the hemotoxin feature
but we pick out some feature then from
there we have to train the classifier
in the case of bayesian decision forest
we have to paint over the objects that
we want and obviously that we don't want
and it will learn how to distinguish
this
in the case of k-means it can do this
without supervised learning
so these are intelligent classifiers
we're not actually setting any cut
points
we're not programming it we're just
telling it what we want and what we
don't want
and letting it decide how to categorize
those pixels
so now for the deep learning class of r
deep learning uses things called
neural networks but if it's only one
hidden layer it's not really a deep
network you need to have multiple hidden
layers
so the network on the left is one layer
and that's really
shallow learning this is still part of
machine learning and not considered deep
learning
if we talk about deep neural networks
we're talking usually about more than
two
sometimes two is enough but more than
one absolutely to be deep
right how deep is the network
so when we talk about deep learning and
visio farm we're really talking about
representational learning or feature
learning
we're using these different layers of
the network to learn or establish a
feature
and we can use both supervised and
unsupervised
however typically we're talking about
supervised learning in the context of
image analysis
in this so if we take an example like
this to highlight the difference
if you had a supervised approach a
pathologist based on their prior
experience would lay down labels to
train the algorithm
in this case green is tumor and blue is
stroma or this is something other than
tumor
and the software will learn that feature
for us
so it will create a probability map
based on one of the classes that we lay
down
to say this is what we're finding and
this is the probability that it belongs
in that class
the goal is that the algorithm can
eventually take in new inputs
and independently predict the correct
label for the data
unsupervised learning does not require
provided labels
and corresponding outputs instead the
algorithm sifts through the unlabeled
input data
and identifies patterns it will use to
group the data
it is unsupervised because it is not
taught with labeled inputs
the algorithm is responsible for
analyzing the underlying structure in
the data
either way we could use these features
further down in our analysis
all right so now that we understand
where each of these classifiers
fits into those terminology buckets how
do we choose the right classifier
so here we'll outline some questions to
ask yourself before choosing a
classifier
they're not all the questions you may
ask but they'll give you a head start
so first how many different pixels or
object classes am i trying to separate
is it two is it five is it seven how
many classes am i working with
then are there any pre-analytical
variables i need to account for in my
image
are there artifacts bubbles or
differences in focus
are there differences in staining
intensities are there differences in
disease states
in these images i just want to point out
that these are very critical in choosing
a classifier
and how to handle that pre-analytical
variability
is there a marker is there an ihc or ish
stain
is it bright field or fluorescence is
there a special stain
something that allows me to easily
distinguish the pixels or objects that i
may want to classify
or is the analysis relying on the
morphology of an object
is it the shape or texture that is the
only thing that distinguishes it from
a certain compartment or an object from
everything around it in the same line as
the ihc can i clearly distinguish the
object by eye
it may be a single hemotoxin stain but i
may be able to clearly see the
differences between objects based on the
intensity of that hemotoxin
or the texture of it that i may be able
to utilize lastly how soon do i need the
results
i know this may seem like an odd one but
some of these classifiers take
time so if it's not something that you
need tomorrow or next week
or you're using it routinely you may
choose to use a different classifier
that just gets you the answer right now
and you move on so i'm going to give you
a couple examples here
on the first one we're going to want to
separate tissue from glass
which is just generating a region of
interest around the tissue
in this example we have two joints and
they have different special stains on
them
so going back to our questions here how
many classes do i need here to separate
tissue from glass
this is just two classes tissue and
glass
do i have any pre-analytical variables
yes they have considerable differences
in the stains of each of these joints
that have to be handled by the
classifier is it distinguishable by eye
yes it's easy to see the differences
between tissue and glass in this example
is there a clear color contrast
absolutely just like if it was
distinguishable by eye we can clearly
see where the tissue is and where the
glass is
so it's easily distinguishable with a
clear color contrast
does it rely on morphology no in this
regard we have the color we don't need
anything morphologically to tell us what
these compartments are
so how quickly do i need it i need it
now i don't want to spend a whole lot of
time building an app to segment these
two things
unless it's something that i'm doing all
the time there's a lot of pre-analytical
variables such as folds or other
differences bubbles or artifacts
that i need to overcome on a routine
basis so i want to know this is just one
study i want to get through it and get
the data
so based on these answers i would say
that deep learning and thresholds are
avenues that i wouldn't take
deep learning simply because of the time
there's really no need to build the
training data set and train and learn
classifiers for something as simple as
tissue versus glass
because there's a clear contrast we
don't need the deep learning network to
find
features for us we can easily see those
features
and threshold although it could be used
because there's a lot of variance in the
staining or pre-analytical variability
in the different stains
it'll just take me a little bit longer
to use threshold than it would to use an
intelligent classifier here
so you could use it but again how
quickly now not going to use threshold
so bayesian just paint on tissue paint
on glass this is a quick
easy result decision force looks very
similar
it's a little more pixelated in this
case but nothing that post-processing
can't handle
and then k-means clustering looks very
similar to bayesian and decision forest
you could pick whichever one you want in
this case k-means has its own caveats
which we'll get to in the next example
but any of these machine learning
classifiers except for deep learning
would work well in this example
so in this example we want to know what
regions or percent of the tissue is
invasive or cancerous tissue which is a
ck 7 19 positive to do this we need to
quantify the areas of ck7
and 19 positive tissue and the areas of
ck7
19 negative tissue we also want to
recognize and exclude the glass areas so
that we get a good denominator
in terms of our tissue sample if we run
down our questions how many classes do
we want to separate
in this case we have three we have a ck
719 positive
a ck 719 negative and the glass
is there any pre-analytical variability
in this case no
the staining is pretty consistent and we
don't have a whole lot of variability
across our sample
we have a clear contrast and a great
signal to noise i'm not worried about
any pre-analytical variables for this
specific sample
is it distinguishable by eye yes we have
a ck 719 marker for it
is there a clear color contrast yes we
have an easily distinguishable
compartment
no need to worry about that does it rely
on morphology no because we have that
clear color contrast in the marker you
do not need to use the texture context
of those compartments
how quickly do i need it i'd like it now
if i had just separated tissue and glass
and this was just the same study and i
wanted to now distinguish these
compartments and i spent the time
working up these essays i should get it
pretty readily
there's no reason to make a super robust
learning classifier out of this
so deep learning is really the one that
i would remove because we have all the
other things that are telling us to use
a machine learning classifier
or threshold to do this so the first one
here is bayesian
you paint where the ck 7 19 positive
areas are
where the ck 719 negative areas are and
where the glass areas are
and it simply learns this super easy and
you could post process to clean this up
decision forest gives us almost the
exact same thing
k means on the other hand we just used
an unsupervised approach here
where we just said we have three classes
find them you can see here that it
distinguishes things a bit differently
and that's one of the caveats with k
means it kind of does its own thing on
the unsupervised front
you can definitely train it but if you
don't have these classes represented in
each field of view
you'll have to always lay these classes
down
so k-means is typically one that i don't
use very often just because of this need
for it to lay down the class every
single time
and lastly we have threshold which looks
very similar to the decision forest
invasion
so in this regard you could use all four
of these i probably would stick with
threshold
bayesian or decision forest but it's
completely up to you
the last example deals with tumor burden
so let's say we just have a hemotoxin
stain and we want the area of the tumor
and the area of the sample so we'll go
back to our questions
how many classes do we have two we have
a tumor and everything else
do you have any pre-analytical variables
yes there's differences in disease
severity
just within the same tissue but also
among different samples
so we'll need to be aware of the
variability of what the tumor is
what the normal compartments are things
like that
is it distinguishable by eye yes a
trained eye can easily see where the
tumor is
and where the non-tumor areas are is
there a clear color contrast
no some of these areas here you can see
the lymphoid components and things are
the connective tissue they have similar
color but they don't provide a whole lot
of contrast
however the texture creates a nice
contrast and the density of these
different nuclei but there's not really
a clear color contrast
does it rely on morphology yes that's
what i mean by the texture or density of
these nuclei or the shape of them
we can tell that they are using
non-linear human logic to say okay the
nuclei are this size they're kind of
clustered together they're creating some
shapes that look irregular compared to
the normal compartments
so that's what i'm classifying as tumor
how quickly do i need this
in this case it doesn't matter because
we really only have one option and
that's deep learning
none of these other classifiers are
going to get us the robustness that we
need to classify these objects on a
routine basis
so we train a deep learning classifier
and we get our results
so in summary thresholding is one of the
easiest classifiers to use and gives you
ultimate control
but it relies on advanced development of
features to become as robust as the
machine learning classifiers
except deep learning deep learning is
one of those classifiers that because it
generates its own features
you don't need to spend a whole lot of
time on that so you should be using
threshold when you have high contrast
between objects that does not rely on
morphometry
and you need a result faster than the
time it takes to train a deep learning
classifier
one of the things i'd like to point out
here is the ultimate control so the nice
thing about thresholding is if you go to
a new study
and it's simply a difference in let's
say nuclear intensity or the marker of
interest
its intensity has changed but it's
consistent you can quickly fine tune
that and you don't have to train
anything
it's just ready to go the remaining
machine learning classifiers which are
k-means
bayesian and decision forest everything
other than deep learning
can quickly tackle most image analysis
tasks
and each has a slight advantage you can
use these for quick app development when
contrast between objects being
classified as high and the need for
tunability is low
so if you need a lot of tunability i
would go with the threshold but
otherwise if you have high contrast
feel free to use any of the machine
learning classifiers besides deep
learning
deep learning can be used to classify
nearly everything but it requires
developing a robust training set and
time to learn
which is why the time constraints that
we highlighted in the examples
are something that you need to assess up
front so use
deep learning when morphometry is really
the only differentiator and or the study
has high heterogeneity and either
disease
or pre-analytical variabilities
deep learning is really the best
classifier but it does take time
we have some other webinars where we
really focus solely on deep learning
how to use it how to train it how to
quality control its performance things
like that
but i hope today was a nice general
summary of how to differentiate ai
machine learning and deep learning and
how those kind of fit in within the
software
and how we can utilize that terminology
more appropriately
one more important thing to take away is
that ai
is not really similar to how the human
brain works
this is very complicated and there are
teams of researchers that are currently
trying to reverse engineer these
mechanisms
however this technology uses
mathematical models that are inspired by
the human brain
each of these are a unique and powerful
entity on their own but both of these
tools working together
can greatly improve outcome and for me
it is really fun to see how ai is
helping the field of healthcare evolve
and advance thanks for your time today
and be sure to check out our virtual
booth in the exhibition hall
thank you for listening and have a great
day